if you're building one of these please
reach out to me i want to invest in all
of these i want to invest in like 20 of
these companies
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel
so we're going to talk about what you
guys can expect in today's episode but
before we do
um so my first million we actually just
went from 80th in
in our category on on the itunes store
which is a big deal to us to like
number 14. and one of the reasons why we
did it was because you folks who are
listening
have clicked the subscribe button so if
you're using itunes or using an apple
product
can you please do me a favor uh i want
you to go
and click subscribe so go to uh our my
first million page and click that
subscribe button
and then we have this email address um
mfm so my first million mfm
at the hustle dot co send a screenshot
of you subscribe and we're gonna do a
call out of you
on the podcast so say like your name and
then show me that you subscribed
send it to mfm a screenshot and we're
gonna uh give a call out and actually
we're gonna give a call out at the end
of this episode
for all the people that did that
previously and now let's hear what we're
gonna talk about in this episode go
ahead sean
uh yeah we got a bunch of topics i'm
excited about we talked about creating
bar stool sports
for the tech industry we talked about
internal
company podcasting platforms like spoken
uh we went on a
crazy detour for crime walks
manhood as a service rent a chicken we
had a bunch of good topics in this
week's uh
in today's episode this was probably if
you like ideas i would say
you're gonna love this episode sometimes
we're a little bit light on ideas we
were
super heavy on ideas today so i think
you guys will love it great
see you in the episode
so we we just were talking for a few
minutes about the podcast updates
uh and what we're doing to make it grow
but what i was about to tell you sean is
i have this doc that i'm going to send
to you and so you know have you seen how
i don't know if you've seen this or not
but
the podcast goes in the email i think
every day now
oh and i have not seen that yeah and i'm
the one writing it and so i have a
we set this up so it's gonna the you're
gonna see the clicks in this document
that i sent you
every day um but anyway it's going well
today did you see that graph i sent you
i tweeted it out i was like this is what
i'm talking about
uh there's a basically you sent a graph
of the
itunes rankings for us business for the
business category i would get i guess
pretty big category and um maybe we
usually hovered between 80 and 100
like we were number 80 number 100 i
guess like that was kind of like our
norm
and then sam takes over growth and like
boom
step change we're up to no we're we're
now ranked number 20 for the last i
don't know a week or two
um you could just see when you started
working on it it's like a direct thing
which
reminds me of like a very uh a lesson i
always teach everybody on our team
because there's lots of marketing things
you'll do where you're like did it work
and it's like i don't know we got to
look into it oh it wasn't trackable it's
like no no
just show me the revenue graph show me
the user graph like
if i can't notice something happened on
this day
or hey we started growing around this
time then it didn't work enough
right like because usually when you're
in a small project
you need step changes you don't need one
percent you need 10 30
50 type of changes uh to work and
basically where we are now is
i mean you and i could are both very
capable of doing this
you just kind of look at the it takes
about two weeks it took about took me
about
two weeks to talk to people and to look
at the numbers and it's like oh
okay i now know that if i only do this
i'm gonna be mostly there
right um and what i've learned now
is it's getting people to click the
subscribe button on itunes
if i get people to do that mostly
everything will will be fine
okay but that's gonna sound uh overly
simplistic it's like
yeah all i gotta do is get checkmate and
then i win a game of chess like well
yeah but
uh how do you get people to click the
subscribe button that's kind of the
question i mean
it is it is not overly simplistic it is
simple it is get people to click that
button
now the not simple part is how i'm going
to get people to click the button
but the way to grow is simple i just get
people to click that button
and we've got loads of ways for one i'm
just asking people
so we um we asked people to leave a
review
uh the other day and when i asked people
to leave the review that day we had 600
reviews do you know how many reviews
we have now i don't know if there's at
least a few hundred that came through
yeah 1400 okay so we added 800 reviews
just off of a quick one minute ask hey
if you like the podcast go review it
uh we really appreciate it that's kind
of all you offered really
it wasn't quick i like begged and i
begged them
but yeah right it was sincere uh
yeah what i'm saying is it wasn't like
rocket science so
you you know i guess like one of the
reasons i want to share how we grow this
podcast is because
the way we grow this podcast is kind of
going to be hold on mosquito on my desk
no too slow uh okay so one of the ways
that we're going to grow this pod
or one of the reasons we talk about this
is because the things you're doing now
is stuff that people can learn to grow
whatever their thing is
and so i would say so far two
observations number one
intensity uh when sam does something he
really like
throws himself in in a you know a more
intense way than the average person the
average person thinks they're doing it
and then we watch sam's level of like
aggression and intensity towards
something you're like oh okay
that's what a level 12 is like now i
know what now i know what the sort of
theoretical max is
okay so that's one lesson uh i get to
see i guess other people don't get to
see on a daily basis but
whatever second thing is start with the
stupid simple stuff okay
we want subscribers well have we just
asked people to subscribe
right like have we tweeted saying go
subscribe have we said it on the podcast
hey make sure you subscribe to this
thing
go push this button and um that takes
zero effort but actually yielded like
gain because it was just low-hanging
fruit
and i i know that a lot of smart people
would have talked themselves out of that
because they would be afraid to ask
uh anybody for anything they're just
afraid of getting rejected afraid of
coming across as a
you know salesperson or beggar or
whatever so they're just afraid to ask
and secondly they would have over
complicated things they would have said
well i gotta go do this sophisticated
strategy and it's like wait well
have you tried the dumb strategy first
yes
uh i completely agree uh and like
that's why i always make a joke that
when i meet really smart people like we
we interviewed um biology the other day
and
i i don't know when that's gonna come
out in relation to this when this
podcast is coming out but soon
and he was like one of the most high iq
people i've ever spoke to i think he
might have been the highest iq person
i've ever talked to
and it was very obvious and when i was
talking to him i actually was wondering
i'm like you know for the longest time i
actually thought
that the lower your iq like you want
your iq to be just above
average but not really high because the
really smart people i meet other than
him
they typically talk themselves out of
anything and
and so anyway i actually think that
being just slightly above average is
optimal
that's the sweet spot i didn't get to
ask him that but i would i would love to
know his opinion of that
of like because like when you meet him
and he must know that he's like a
kind of a genius um right he can't kind
of because you know he's gonna be
humble about it he's not gonna say yeah
clearly i'm smarter than everybody but
he is clearly smarter than everyone
so i know where you're going with this
top one and i
think i've got a i've got a strong
opinion on it you want to do your bar
stool for tech
you've talked about this many times okay
yeah so so maybe we'll keep it short but
well i don't know i mean you i know what
you said but we ha
with our listeners they probably don't
okay so bar stool to me is a super
interesting company not just
i'm interested i'm a fan i i consume
some of the content but
i'm more interested in the business
behind it so they basically went into
sports media which was dominated by espn
and they you know the upstart made it
they started with nothing
literally dave portnoy was you know
writing
a newspaper himself and then going down
to the subway and handing it out to
people on before they got on their their
morning commute
that's how that was the humble origins
of that not even like a blog
like a physical newspaper he was handing
out like the paperboy and he was the
writer
um and he was the editor right and so so
that's how we got started and then
ultimately you know they sold for i
don't even know you probably know
675 650ish yeah
so so great outcome and like you know
they actually mean something in the
world a lot of people really love bar
stool they care about barcelona great
so why doesn't this exist in the world
of business or the
world of tech so what did bar stool do
and could you apply that here
so what barstool did if you listen to
dave's early interviews he basically
says look
um i want we are an entertainment
company
so that's that's the first thing we are
trying to make people laugh and have a
good time
if you go to espn that's not their mind
that's not their mindset their mindset
is
news information analysis um and yes we
are entertainment but like
we're entertainment through news
information um
you know official game games and uh and
analysis
and barstool has no no rights to the
games they don't bid for it they don't
they don't own any nba games they don't
know nfl games
um they don't do much analysis they
don't do much sort of
information they don't they don't tell
you the news they don't tell you who won
and lost and how many points they
scored but they really focus on that
last bit which is making people laugh
and being entertained and so i think the
world of business is full of
espn's it's full of information analysis
um you know like kind of like official
broadcast of of content you know whether
it's you know
interviews with the companies and
whatever i think somebody should make
barstool for tech
which is i'm here to make you laugh
you're you're into the business world
you're into the tech world the startup
world whatever it is pick your niche
and um every day we're gonna report news
that makes you laugh and
today there's like the onion that does
that so i would say that's like an
example of someone who does that
uh but they're very extreme and maybe
that's the right way to go
um there was like kind of valley wag or
these kind of gossip blogs so they took
gossip and they brought it to
business and tech they kind of got sued
out of business later but they were
popular for for
a time um and there's kind of nobody
else and i think that if there is a dave
portnoy out there if there's somebody
who's interested in this stuff
and they're funny as hell or they have
this comedic taste
you could build a media company doing
this that's my theory i feel like you
disagree give me give me your take
yeah so i don't disagree with you i
think it would work
if you could pull it off i want to
explain to you why this is hard to pull
off
so when you're a sports journalist who
happens to be funny which i
actually think a lot of those people
start they're like they love sports and
they're happy to be funny and
and that's typically how it works now
you don't really have
that many options you can work for the
local newspaper
you can try to get one of the few jobs
at espn but regardless
if you're lucky you make a hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year right right
and you're tabling the comedy side nine
times out of ten you're like uh you know
i would say this joke in my text message
group with my buddies but i can't put it
in my column on espn
if you're smart enough to do this for
business
and you're funny you now here's the
where the rub
you likely can get paid a ton of money
as some type of analyst or some type of
investor
or some type of operator right and so
it's really
hard to retain those types of people
because they say well why would i make
like if i'm this smart i'm just going to
go and trade stocks or
invest in companies or start a company
versus give you my opinion and make you
laugh for eighty thousand dollars
and this is the problem i've always had
at the hustle which is
how do you actually like a lot of the
people who are best at and analyzing
companies
and giving opinions they sold their
company for 80 million dollars
and so i have found it's quite hard to
retain those people whereas
if you are a journalist in sports that's
like
the end goal is to be a journalist in
sports right do you know what i mean
whereas when you cover this stuff
the end goal is to start or join an
early stage company that's going to be
massive
and so i agree with you that you could
pull this off or that if you could pull
it off it would be a huge hit
it's just that that's one of the hard
parts right
and so so i i agree with you there are
uh
there's higher opportunity cost for a
smart business person who has a good
sense of humor to do many things but but
but
here's the kicker i think this could be
fun i think this could be cool
and i think that there's enough people
out there that aren't
gonna know how to parlay their you kind
of need just above average iq
and then two standard deviations above
average uh like kind of internet
funniness um
to make this work and so here's my pitch
there's the camera i gotta look at
trung i'm looking at you charlie look at
the look at these eyes i'm looking at
you right now
trung this is what you should do my
friend you need to you need to leave the
hustle you need to leave hubspot
and you need to create the bar stool for
tech you already are doing it on twitter
and you need to create it but here's the
kicker here's how you make it more
valuable it's not just a media company
this would actually be an investment
fund so you would be a vc fund
whose brand is built through journalism
whose distribution of how they help
their companies
is through their media arm and so you're
a media arm whose business model
is your vc fund and that's actually what
i was going to say is i think
that would work but you need to be a vc
fund
first who then hires content people and
offers them like some upside there
you're a vc fund in disguise is kind of
how it started because you do have to
build up you know good distribution and
it's not again i don't think it would be
hard because there's nobody
really creating this type of content
there's nobody that will just straight
up
make fun of zuck when he's talking like
a robot somewhere right like
uh and that's the type of stuff that
dead spin and bar stool that they do
they
they find funny memeable moments and
they talk about them and
and that that's why trump came to mind
because he did a tweet the other day
about uh
steve ballmer and it was like
information it was like
steve ballmer did you know when he first
joined microsoft this was his salary
and then he renegotiated and was able to
get this much equity that turned him
into a
30 billionaire or whatever he is now and
by the way he did the whole thing
he has this like steve ballmer in four
decades and each time he's wearing the
same
white you know new balance dad shoes and
he's like he did this the whole time
wearing these new balance shoes like
anything is possible
and i was like this is the perfect blend
of a useful information nugget wrapped
in
a joke poking fun at the bear and um and
so i think that that's a that's that's
the model so anyways i'm bullish on this
sorry for trying to poach uh trying to
convince him to go do this but i think
that would be the
ultimate manifestation of his talents or
somebody who's like chung if you're the
next chung out there i don't know you so
i'm not
i'm not saying trunk is this i'm also
not saying trung is not this
but when you hire these types of people
because what makes them good also makes
them
a pain in the ass to work but sometimes
you know like
what makes them good is that they're
they're hilarious
they come up with stuff like off the
cuff
uh but they're incredibly challenging to
contain
um and you don't want to contain them
necessarily but like there is some [__]
you need people to do
i'm kind of like this right i showed up
10 minutes late today i know you hate me
being late i wasn't trying to be late
but i'm late but also i'm good i'm good
at what i do you could find so many
shows up on time for the podcast
but it's hard to find somebody who's
going to consistently great create great
content
right that's the rub with talent
i've learned how to put up with that but
that is the part
where sometimes i'm like ugh i should
just start a software company where the
code is never late and the code never
complains about x y and z
not right this isn't a trunk trunk i
love you this is just
me as well i'm a create i'm a creative
person as well i'm like that and so
creative people are hard to contain
um you want to talk about slips because
you were
quite uh interested in this okay so
check out
dude why don't you always say i don't
think you're gonna like am i like a
default i probably i
posted it i posted it in slack and you
go i hate course businesses
so that's what i'm basing this on you're
like why are you saying i hate this like
you literally
an hour ago a company that publishes
courses i think is awesome to own
horrible to invest in am i wrong uh
i don't know maybe what do you mean
company that publishes courses so who's
that
like what uh well no teachable is a
platform
um this is a platform so let me explain
what this is so
the domain is slip.so and it's a company
i'm looking at potentially investing in
i saw it and it immediately was like oh
this is a smart idea so what did they do
they make it easy for any developer to
create a course
to teach you know some programming you
know either a language or
how to make x or how to make x go faster
or whatever right any
developer teaching other developers so
why do you need so why do you need a new
platform for this why can't you just use
udemy or udacity or one of the other 10
platforms
well those platforms are all teaching
through video so you
upload a video and maybe some text or
pdf and
um and then people go take that course
self-serve what they did was a little
bit different they
took the today the best ways to learn
how to code online or interactive
like we talked about codecademy uh or is
it code
academy i don't know but codeacademy.com
yeah yeah
i'm going to say it fast so i don't you
don't know what i'm saying if i'm saying
it right or wrong cudaway activity.com
you go there i think they have like 40
million users or something it's really
grown over time
it's a thing and all it is is it's a
like you don't have to have it's the
like if you ever tried to learn how to
code first you got to download the like
the text editor that's what you're going
to use to write your code and then you
got to
download like the python packages so you
can like deploy
what the [__] is all this i don't even
know what python is yet but you need
that to get started so what codecad we
did was brilliant was
they just put it all on the website all
in the browser so you go to the website
there's a place to type and you don't
have to install anything you have to
download anything it just says
look right variable equals a
now you made a variable called a
fantastic that's you know level one
complete level two
let's do a plus one and like you do it
and it and if you get it wrong
a little hint pops up it's like a game a
hint pops up and says
type a plus one so anyways or you're
missing a comma or whatever
so um so code academy built this and
they are a teacher
so what slip did was they made a
platform but they made the code academy
like sandbox or toolkit available for
any dev so let's say i'm a developer and
i'm really good at front-end development
and
making parallax scrolling websites so
i want to teach that but i don't want to
have to build the underlying
infrastructure that codecademy built
in order to just let students come learn
from me that's way too much work
so what this is is it's code academy to
box any developer can now create a
interactive course and teach other
developers and they can make money for
sharing what they know
so i think this is pretty cool i like
the idea of
letting developers become teachers i
think we're going to want more
programmers over time
and i think that the building that
underlying sandbox that infrastructure
that lets anybody have this kind of like
codecademy in a box i think is a
cool innovation that's going to save
people a lot of time so i'm kind of
bullish on this
but it's very very early there's not
much traction uh you know just got
started what do you think
hmm have you done the math behind this
like how many
so he charges i think if you are a
developer who's using it i think it's he
charges 30 bucks a month plus 10
of the sales for your course that's his
business model he himself
taught a course so how did he arrive
here he created a course on learning vim
i don't know what vim is but it's some
[__] delivers use so vim's like you're
it's basically like you're you know uh
you're uh it's kind of like your
your virtual machine basically about how
you organize and write your code i think
uh or maybe it's something completely
different sean doesn't know so
he created a vim course and in order to
do that he me he built the
infrastructure for himself so that his
students would have an interactive way
to learn this
instead of just watching videos and
trying to figure it out themselves
they'd have a
sandbox to go go and write the code to
learn he made 10 15 000
selling that course and then he was like
oh dude i should make this any developer
like i know vim
but what about the next guy who knows
solidity and they're trying to teach
ethereum programmers you know how to
write in solidity
they can now create their course using
the same toolkit that i i create i use
for myself
so i wish she would have started this
like six years ago so right now
these course businesses are actually
these course platforms we're going to
call them they're not publishers they're
tech companies
they're actually booming right now so do
you know a company called thinkific
i've heard of it but it's it's kind of
like a kajabi right it's like
just a it's like a teachable it's the
same thing right do you know they went
public yesterday
i did not know this how how big is it
they went public yesterday on the
canadian stock exchange
uh the toronto the t s e is that what
it's called
toronto stock exchange and look it up
right now
for some reason when companies write
like in the first couple days of going
public it's like impossible to find the
market cap i don't understand why it's
so hard but it never shows up
but anyway they only had 20 million in
sales and they broke even or lost a
little bit of money
so they went from 10 million to 20
million in 2020
and guess what their market cap is right
now
it's gonna be like uh two billion
dollars or something stupid it's over a
billion dollars their market cap is
and i was i asked don cor so our friend
ankur he started this company called
teachable when teachable sold
they sold for i think 250 million it's
this is uh
uh public information just google
whatever the headline says that's what
that's what i'm trying to say
yeah i think it's 250 ish and i think he
was only doing
25 million a year in sales if they had
only raised four million dollars it was
a really straightforward simple thing i
mean hard but simple
and now thinkific is quite similar they
went public
at with a huge massive valuation and i
was like ankur why are these
valuations so high like this is just
stupid and he goes it's because
of and i don't understand how this i
don't understand this but he's like
it's the payments business so i guess
once you get someone to start spending
you save their credit card and then
they'll continue buying stuff and that's
one of the reasons why
investors value these companies
incredibly highly at the moment is
because they want the payments revenue i
don't entirely understand
i don't i don't understand mechanics
there but the way i would think about it
is these are just shopify so what does
shopify do shopify maybe
anybody can create a storefront what
they're saying is it's shopify but
instead of selling you know hats and
shirts
you sell information which is super high
margin
and if you think okay shopify there are
now x
number of hundreds of thousands of
sellers and shopify is a hundred billion
dollar company
um okay maybe retail is bigger than the
sort of
uh you know additional education
business but
um but you know we have a hundred fold
you know from a hundred billion which is
shopify to
1 billion uh you know you can you can be
100 times smaller than shopify if you
create
shopify for education if you make it so
that any educator can come
and create a storefront to sell their
their information and that's what
teachable is trying to do that's what
many companies try to do they're all
splitting that pie in a way
but i like this one because i think it
doesn't compete with all those i think
the developer ecosystem you know
developers
teaching other developers or want to be
developers is
quite differentiated and the product is
quite differentiated from what
teachable like teachable kajabi
thinkific they're all the same
it's just you create a video library you
charge students they get access to the
library
and then you know the teacher can
communicate with the students or
whatever
i was on twitter i think i just saw i
don't know i don't know
maybe one of my guys sent it to me i
don't really recall um
i think zack actually who is my scout
for my phone i think he saw it
i was like this is cool and i was like
as soon as i went to the landing page
something
clicked with me now this is still very
small i think can you i think he's
under a thousand dollars of gmb right
now like i think he's got like a couple
teachers who it's been live for a couple
weeks
and uh you know he's getting a thousand
dollars
what's that what's it called slip sl
what's the url slip so
um yeah look it's neat i think i've
always had a little bit of a problem
with this type of stuff because
whenever do you know what the finish
rate is for courses you know it's like
10 60 yeah like so uh
a hundred people buy it only 10 if you
consider using the product doing the
whole thing only like 10 of the 100 are
actually going to do it if you're lucky
i have a friend who just sold he's doing
a course it's a couple
thousand dollar ticket price right so
people putting down a few thousand
dollars to learn this thing
and uh he said guess how many people are
finishing the course
uh i was like oh no don't tell me
it was like i think i think 12 people
had finished the course
it was like you know whatever less less
than less than six percent i think had
actually finished the course
he also said guess some people got to 50
i think it was like
20 20 something percent of people had
gotten halfway through the course
he's like did i make a shitty course and
i was like no dude this is just what
self-serve education is
when it's self-serve and there's no pure
like peer pressure there's no like
accountable teacher who's like training
you every week or you know you're
showing up to a live
live thing when it's it's netflix it's
on demand i can go
i can go learn more whatever i want i
paid for the thing even paying thousands
of dollars is not enough skin in the
game to do this it's very
counterintuitive
it's not even you you paid 60 grand a
year or whatever you paid or your
someone paid to for you to go to duke
and you missed classes
oh yeah that's a great point yeah i was
uh i basically you know
for four years i took a four-year piss
down the drain of my uh
my college tuition this is the way i
would describe that experience
so anyway that's one of the reasons why
i'm not like all
gung-ho about course businesses because
i'm like damn like no one uses your [__]
i'll say this not all have that low
complete rate i invested in
maven uh guggens you know guggenbein's
company he did udemy
he saw that low completion rate problem
he created this cohort based course
uh product where you get a batch of
people in
they're gonna do the thing for a defined
period of time five weeks there's live
instruction every week
and the completion rates are way better
right like that that
dramatically increases it lambda school
i invested in lambda school
lambda school had like 80 completion
rate when i invested way back in the day
and so i knew something is different
about this company i knew the standard
is six i knew these guys had 80 plus
and i was like what'd you get different
he goes well it's live uh you show up to
class with a bunch of other students and
a teacher
and um you know so and we do good
filtering up top
most course companies they're trying to
sell as many seats as possible
lambda school is the opposite it's like
at harvard they're trying to only accept
the one percent of students that are
actually going to do the thing
and so you know depending on the
business you can get wildly different
outcomes but yeah you're right as
a general rule they're com you know the
usage kind of sucks dude you have so
many ideas here where did you find all
this so what the hell is um
you inspired me dude you were working on
growth and i was like
if he's doing growth i better bring the
[__] heat on content so i was like
i'm coming with a bunch of ideas what
the [__] is spoken
sounds sick yes okay you wanna do spoken
so spoken
s-p-o-k-n it's podcasting inside
companies
what's the url s-p-o-k-n i don't know
you'd have to google it i don't have the
url i did i
i i it's so new they don't even show up
really
oh [__] sad because i'm giving this guy
a shout out they're growing fast got it
if you it's getspoken.com or if you just
google
s-p-o in quotation marks you'll find it
right and tell them i sent you so um
okay so what is this so i
when i first started this podcast i used
to record out of a studio
and in san francisco there's like this
old radio station
place and they were like ah radio's kind
of dying what if we converted these
radio studios to podcast studios and so
they were the only one in san francisco
uh if you just like google for it
it's kind of amazing 100 bucks an hour
go record and um
and so i wanted good quality so i went
there and i used to book like on their
little scheduler and some days i would
see it was just like all booked
and i was talking to the dude and i was
like who the hell is booking how many
podcasters are using this thing i feel
like
it was like not many people yeah would
do and he was like oh
sorry that day uh facebook booked all
the hours i was like what do you mean
facebook booked all the hours facebook i
have a podcast i go
oh facebook has tons of podcasts
internally i was like what
because yeah they have like a managers
manager's podcast
that is just a internal podcasting uh
podcast for facebook managers to talk
about managing inside facebook
and i was like oh that's actually kind
of smart like we've talked about this
before
internal media companies i think this is
a big opportunity you think it's a big
opportunity
we've talked about it from a blogging
point of view newsletters
um we've talked about it on like uh like
kind of like
like central announcement dashboards so
building tools for companies
to better communicate building basically
build an internal high school newsletter
a new high school newspaper i think is
what we called it what is the high
school news
newspaper for your company yeah i think
this is so awesome
ever since you said that i can't get
that idea out of my head if you're
building one of these please reach out
to me i want to invest in all of these i
want to invest in like 20 of these
companies i'm trying to find that
episode
do what would i search to find it on
google my first million internal
internet what do we what terminal mail
mailchimp for companies i think i don't
know what we called it at that time but
the core idea is just like a high school
or college will have their their
school newspaper why don't companies
have the same and if there's gonna be a
newspaper it's not gonna be literally a
physical newspaper in this case with
spoken
it's a podcast for inside companies and
companies will clearly pay
for the like kind of like the platform
the recording the
library and the like private private
feed
um that others can't access that's for
your company
and uh you know the companies that need
this are very large companies
and so i don't know realistically like
okay so i think that's all cool i don't
know realistically
how many people at facebook are like
[__] yeah i'm like commute to work today
i'm gonna listen to the manager podcast
like maybe nobody wants to hear this
[__] uh but maybe they do like maybe
there's interesting personalities i know
that if at twitch
if twitch had an internal like podcast i
would do one i would do one on
you know managing or product or
innovation or whatever i don't know
and i don't know how many people listen
to it but i think it's a very
interesting niche that turns
it's a niche podcasting that is highly
monetizable what do you think
uh yeah so on on the surface i think
this is so badass i've been a fan of
this idea for a long time i don't know
where we came up with this idea but i've
i've
i think that at the time we discussed
this we were like oh this might be one
of the most straightforward ways to make
a lot of money on this podcast that we
had at that time um i'm looking at we
were talking i think we were talking
about it because i was publishing my
three two one
um or my 123 newsletter uh inside twitch
i
had told you hey here's a networking
hack i'm doing inside the company
i write this thing i send it to all the
execs like the 25 person exec team or
whatever
and it's just a great way to stay in
front of people and stay top of mind and
help them get to know me and it takes me
one hour and i get
i essentially get an hour with all the
execs just by me putting the one hour in
um and so but i was saying you know i'm
just sending this in gmail
why isn't there like mailchimp or
convertkit for sending stuff inside
companies that's kind of
one of those great company called recess
it's called recess
dot io and yeah i bet you've grabbed it
so by the way
episode 53 is where we talked about it
if people want to go 53 all right i'm
going to write that
because i'm actually doing this this
series where i'm going to go back and
look at old ideas and this is a good one
um recess dot io it's started by this
guy named ryan dice
it never really got off the ground but
it's called easily send internal email
newsletters and track results
so it's basically what you're we're
describing and it hasn't taken off i'm
also looking at spoken they went to
white combinator
they're in class of w21 so winter 21
does that mean they're still in it
yeah that's like now um and they cut the
company launched into so that's like not
even now it's [__] spring 21 i don't
know how that works
wait yeah what the hell that's guys
lying it says w-21 no well it could be
winter 21 january january 21
oh okay i gotcha i guess yeah not
december january
uh and it started in 2018
and i'm wondering why it hasn't taken
off a little bit more
because it's three years in you would
think it would have a little bit more
traction and so
on surface i think this is a brilliant
idea i'm wondering what's going on and
why it's not kicking ass
i think this is a fantastic idea all
right
uh i i like this idea a little better as
the newsletter one
because i think it's more accessible
than podcasts but uh both are cool
and we should ask ryan dies is your
buddy right you should ask him like
what's what's the deal why
well i don't he's never told me this but
ryan dice has loads of companies
right so this is because of
because this is pretty innovative you'd
have to be all in on it i think to make
it work
and so i was wondering what's going on
with something like this so if you're
building this let us know
if you're like no i want a project i
want to build it this is one where if
you're a credible person
uh me and sam will invest in this i
think to to get something like this
built
by the way um we have a new email it's
called mfn
at thehustle.com i'll give you access
sean but basically um
any because i get too many emails i
think you do too so if you guys want to
contact us and if you are building this
mfm at
thehustle.com uh so you can email us us
if you're actually making that
uh you want to go then another one yeah
let's do another one all right so
um crime walk okay what is this so
i was i don't even remember what this
was so basically there's like an air so
airbnb has this experiences thing
and uh you probably know much more about
this and uh your wife works there and
you're also i think the type that would
do something like this so
i saw this and i saw how much money it
was making or i don't remember what it
was exactly
okay so if you go to airbnb experiences
there was a experience and there's a
in our dock there's a link to it just
slightly below um
where it's a retired nypd officer
will guide you for a
this is so cool so here's the
description i'm just going to read it
word for word
first let me say that most gangster
tours in new york are total bs
this experience comes right from the
horse's mouth no tour guide no filter
get real stories while visiting
notorious gang land locations as we walk
from east village to little italy
experiencing what it was like to
associate to be an associate of new
york's famous mafia families
you'll hear first-hand accounts of the
new york new york city mafia and crimes
in new york
and taste local cuisines so i i saw this
i was like this is a
such a good idea uh i i think i saw that
this crime walk was making a lot of
money so
it was very successful which is not a
surprise to me i i would do this if i
was
you know in new york this is this is
great um
but a couple of things kind of here's
the business idea so first is this is
cool
quick reaction then i have an idea well
on
okay so this first of all i just sent
this to my wife because we're moving to
new york for a little while i said we're
doing this
second he charges around 120 to 130
depending on the date per person
and in the description he says that he
has had 8 000 guests
so 123 times 8 000 is a million bucks
exactly so a mill i think that's what i
that's what originally caught my
attention was
here's who has built an experience i
think that was my kind of curiosity
who's built an airbnb experience
that had made a million bucks right
because this is a big platform
certainly somebody's doing well uh and
so so this is kind of how it caught my
eye okay so
what's the idea the idea is
this is a cool thing for a cop to do in
retirement i
i told you we had that uh that police
situation where i had to go do a
shakedown we we brought a cop with us
and became friends with that cop later
and was getting to know you know as
the first cop i really become friends
with as an adult um
and i loved her she was great and i said
so i was like well
um what you know how do cops can cops
make more money because she was
describing how hard it is to be a cop
nowadays there's like
kind of like a lot of cop backlash
because of blm and all that stuff she's
like what i'm a good cop
and like also like budget cuts like
defund the police budget cuts are
happening all around
and so anyways long story short i think
this is a cool thing for a retired cop
to do also could be applied to retired
kind of anything
anybody who has a cool job like whether
you're a swat
officer a you know military veteran
firefighter or whatever it is i think
there's a lot of people who
a lot of people who are like me were
like little weaklings that spend all of
our days behind a desk
and we want this like safe way to taste
you know
an adventure and like what the real
tough world looks like
and so that's why like spartan race and
stuff that's why they do well
and similarly i think that these like
kind of crime walks would be would be
cool
so then i took it a little bit further
well why don't people do this with more
things so why don't you take
every physical venue where something
interesting is happening
breweries do this right breweries say
hey we got this brewery
but we also have the side business of
people come through they get a tour of a
brewery they get to see how it's made
they get to taste the beers they get to
take some photos they get to buy our
[__] on the way out
and they've turned brewery tours as a
like
additional income stream for breweries
so why doesn't this happen for more
things like when i visited
uh you know the warehouse for my wife's
you know ecommerce business
i was fascinated this like this 80 000
square foot place
you get to see all these forklifts
coming around and how it works how
fulfillment works when an order comes in
how does it get put in a mailer how does
it get taken out of here and
so i think that for everything factories
warehouses
police stations firefighter stations i
think they should all have this as a
business
vaynermedia did that where and you could
well i don't know about cove anymore but
prior i think it was like a 20 million
dollar a year of business it would cost
like
10 000 10 000 per person or per
like couple and you and your co-founder
or you and whoever can go to the
vaynermedia thing
and they're like head of people would
just have a discussion with you and then
eventually gary would come in for like
half an hour
and all you do is you learn how an
agency works and you get to walk around
the office and see like where the
departments are
and you could go to the eventbrite page
and it would show you how many seats
they had and how many were taken and i
did that and i just did the math i'm
like oh my gosh this might make like 10
to 20 a year if
right like if seven of eight of the
seats are actually full
um it's actually that was 10 grand
yeah it's called the the uh uh
uh if you look at vaynermedia eventbrite
you'll find it it was called
so this is i'm an age i'm a small agency
owner garyvee is my hero
vaynermedia is like where we want to be
someday i'll pay 10 grand to basically
get to go check it out see how it works
meet gary shake his hand
uh spend 20 minutes there and then like
leave is
that basically it yeah it's called the
vaynermedia
daily digital deep buy deep dive
and if you look it up on eventbrite
youtube
yeah it's a dumb name am i right uh
abreu is that what it's called and so if
you look up eventbrite
vaynermedia you'll see it and you could
look at the past events and you can see
how full it is and you can see the price
it's it's pretty ridiculous
but like so i didn't look this up
beforehand but i'll tell you another
version of this that's cool um are you a
basketball fan do you know who coach k
is
yeah duke guy i know i'm i'm i'm i'm not
an idiot but i'm not a fan
okay so the four days by the way it's
called the four d's uh it's called the
four d's
uh vaynermedia four ds i guess that is
daily digital deep dive
okay cool so um so coach k
who is the duke basketball coach he's
the most famous college basketball coach
probably of all time uh and he was the
men's olympic coach for the dream
the the latest dream teams or regime
teams like lebron and kobe and all those
guys
so he's pretty popular guy and
he does a thing every year called coach
k's fantasy camp
it's almost identical to what you're
talking about and now you got my brain
spinning that how many more of these are
there and how many more should there be
and uh maybe we need the my first
million dream camp so here's how this
works
coach case fantasy camp you pay ten
thousand dollars and you get to go who
are these people they are
you know duke students who like you know
there's a bunch of duke students who are
like kind of investors now
ceos of companies and uh they were big
basketball fans now they got a bunch of
money
they're kind of in their 40s or you know
50s and they pay to go to this thing
what is it you go for the
for i think a five-day program or
something like that you go back to duke
campus
and you live like a player so you stay
in the dorms i think or
you know you stay kind of on campus or
right next to campus
um there's like a bus that basically
brings you onto campus and you you come
into cameron indoor stadium which is the
duke basketball stadium it's like the
hallowed ground
and um coach k takes you through a camp
where you you know you're on the court
you're shooting you're doing the drills
that the players do
you get the motivational talk that coach
k gives he brings in old players to come
oh that's carlos boozer oh that's jj
redick
um you know you get autographs and kind
of you know but but it's more intimate
because it's 10 grand
so there's you know a few hundred
campers i think and uh so they actually
get to meet those guys and actually hang
with them and for the players it's cool
too because these are all like
ceos or high level hedge fund guys they
actually kind of want this business
network also
and um you get to wear the jersey you
get to go into the locker room
they play the sounds when you come out
and like you know you've got your dad
bod like your fats coming out the side
of the jersey
here comes here comes duke and you get
to run out and there's like no fans
there because it's not real again
um anyways this thing's awesome he must
make a ton of money off this thing i
haven't really done the math because i
heard about this when i was in college
my roommate
was a manager on the team so he he was
part of the kind of the team program
so he would stay during the summers to
be the the kind of the
uber the shuttle bus driver for these
guys and he's like i was like
why are you doing this sounds lame like
why do you want to do this he's like oh
i make a killing in tips
these guys will just hand me hundreds
when they get out for the 5.5 minute
ride of like from the
from the dorm or the hotel to the to the
gym he's like i'm getting 100 bucks from
these guys every time i do one of these
shuttles it's amazing
and um and the network is great like i
meet some of these guys they're like
hi you know this guy started this this
guy started that so
i think this is cool and i wonder how
many more people do this or could do
this because it's a very interesting
little i think you do it for every sport
and
and i'm so into this i don't know what i
don't know what i could do it with but
um i i'm on board here's here's a
version of this if you're a hustler
um okay so so if you're a hustler here's
what you do
you go to um grant cardone you
go to you know people who are yes
they've made it and they have a high
profile but they actually don't make
as they still need money right so like
you can i don't think you could do this
with lebron james necessarily
but i think you could do this with a
college football coach because college
football coaches like
you know at every program don't make
tons of money
or or a really famous high school coach
yeah exactly or um it could be a ceo of
a company or you know
whatever and you basically create the
same sort of fantasy camp
uh mindset or the 4d tours
and it's like hey i will run this whole
thing for you
i just want 20 of profits okay so here's
what i'm going to ask of you
when i bring people over at this time
every week or once a year or whatever it
is
you come out you kiss babies and shake
hands and let me do this and so it's a
way to attach yourself to an influential
program
institution or person and create this
business line
uh you know from scratch because really
you're just offering this to their
uh their fans dude i think and this is
actually what i've thought about doing
because i enjoy
using i enjoy physical work uh
i whenever i'm done working here
whenever i'm done
i like before i start my next company
i'm what i'm gonna do
is i'm either i'm gonna go and read a
book and i'm gonna master
like a niche like crime in new york or
um the gold rush in san francisco or
something like that
or i'm going to start a landscaping
company something that i'm gonna have to
be outside
all day working really hard and i think
i can turn it into a million dollar a
year company like
inside six months i truly believe and
the reason why this
fascinates me is because hey i i love it
i love like being physically exhausted
i enjoy that but also um because
i think that far too many people are
trying to make money on the internet
which is cool and all
when they could probably crush it and
become quite wealthy by just doing some
something outside that is totally like
so it won't scale yadda yadda i'm like
oh [__] it dude
who like do like you know first of all
everything could scale at least a little
bit
and secondly who cares i would love to
see
somebody do manhood as a service okay
what's manhood as
a service so in this again same way that
spartan race and tough mudder
they're kind of like these like pseudo
tough guy
events that you can go do oh i did
something hard
outdoors i got muddy i got cut
you know i climbed this mountain i got
this headband and i drank a beer at the
end
you know you get your man card now if
anybody who really knows knows that this
is not a real man card this is a
fake id but you know this is your
mclovin it's pretty funny
but that's what these are offering
they're offering manhood as a service
and um
i would like to see somebody take this
to the extreme so i'll give you the
example
uh brother aaron who comes on here he's
coming here twice or something like that
and people know him because people like
him because he's kind of a nut like he
comes on with conspiracies
and rabbit holes and he just goes all in
on things he has
gone all in on like manhood he's sort of
like
dude we're all too soft so he trains
like jiu jitsu
and boxing and he just wants to do an
amateur fight why because he's like i
just want to see what i'm made of
and i think you could take that concept
and make it a weekend
traveling circus it goes from city to
city
you just say step up and
face some pain you want to see what it's
like to get like
kind of tortured you want to get can you
take a punch
can you get like like a tough mudder
there's the electric shock at the end
and you kind of want to know like what
does that feel like
um you know like can you go in this
isolation tank and like could you last
an hour
i don't i don't know what the actual
product is but i know
it's a counter-intuitive thing it's like
wait people are paying to get like
kind of like do physical labor they have
to like chop down this [__] tree and
they don't get picked up until they're
done it's like yeah that's what this is
it's like hard work slash pain
slash like manhood like what did we used
to have to do that we don't have to do
anymore what's hardship
that we are sheltered from because other
people do it for us or machines do it
for us or whatever
and uh i think there's actually like a
very big craving in society for
um for those types of experts i totally
agree i've been going boxing every
friday and i just like
love i'm like i need to get punched in
the face so i can feel alive
um like i gotta do it it's awesome like
again
like tough mudder you make it safe
enough where the actual you the mass
market
is [__] basically who don't actually
want to go get punched like if you
really wanted to
go get a fight you can go do that so you
need the people who want to have the
experience
but with padded walls with you know with
with the
with the gloves on where you're not
actually gonna get like
severely hurt in any way but you get to
experience like what is your level of
toughness grit
pain tolerance uh physical endurance
physical ability what is your max
um like i think survivors should do this
i'm a big survivor
nerd and i always see these challenges
and i would love to do them
and like if you're a survivor okay back
to the camera
jeff probst this idea is for you you're
survivor you're you're
i don't know you're on season 42 or
something like that
you're not getting any younger the show
is not getting that many new users here
newcastle new viewers here's what you
need to do we need to create the
survivor world tour
where you go city to city and you set up
the survivor events that you've seen on
tv and you see
can you do it can you hang what will
this do
survivor super fans have a deeper way to
connect with you they'll pay you know
shut up and take my money because i love
this show you can get the ex players to
come out because they ain't doing [__]
anymore right they're just doing cameos
so they'll come out they'll do it just
to extend their lifeline of fame
you'll get new people who will go with
their friends to go try this thing
they'll get into the survivor universe
and then when i'm watching the show it's
like dude i did that one where you have
to
hang on to this poll for as long as you
can and it's an amusement park or a
carnival or a fair
but branded by one of these shows or
maybe multiple shows that get together
and do this
what do you think of my idea in yeah i
mean
it's almost like um it's like a tv
version of disneyland
yes yes exactly you take the ip from tv
and you make disneyland out of it and as
or or you know uh
uh yeah like any kind of carnival if if
they had like do you remember you know
that tv show the challenge that both you
and like
so sean and my wife sarah like do i
remember the show i watched last week
yes yeah they like text each other about
this thing called the challenge i don't
i don't know how it ended i mean i see
it in the background when sarah's
watching it but they
they love it i thought you're a fan you
didn't even watch the finale
if i don't have anything to do i'll sit
with her and watch it i i have literally
no idea how it ended
uh i think the ending was like last week
right yeah
um if they have like a challenge
location where you could do i know
there's like a famous one called like
wall brawl or something like that paul
brawl yeah
like if they like we would have gone let
me describe hull brawl for people who
don't know because
you know there's not many the crossover
between people who care about business
and tech and watch the challenge
you know it's a lonely lonely island so
halbro is a
imagine a narrow hallway like two feet
wide
it's just plexiglas uh it's a two
plexiglas things with a two foot gap in
between
and on one side there's one person
wearing football pads another person's
standing the other side
and then the guy says go and you have to
run straight at each other in this
narrow hallway you smash into each other
and then it's like whoever gets out to
the other side and rings the bell first
wins
and it's the famous thing there but this
is exactly what i would do in my kind of
manhood as a service
fair or my or my tv fair which is
yeah you can do hall brawl come step up
sign the waiver
step up and you get to do whole brawl
you get to experience this we
there's video cameras already positioned
everywhere and you get to share this
content onto instagram
uh at the end of it just like the museum
of ice cream just like tough mudder
it's due today for photo opportunities
i've all right i've got
we we're probably gonna have to wrap it
up soon but i've got two stories
that i'm gonna bring up the first is i
was at my friend nick ray's house the
other day and i met the founder of
museum of ice cream um and i told him we
talked about him and he was like i know
and i and
we were never disrespectful about him
but i think we were like not
bullish on the idea so we'll have to i
think we were both like this is a great
business idea but hey if you go
kind of underwhelming i think that was
like our both of our like true
user opinion of it so we're gonna have
to have him come on but second
have you heard of museum hack no what is
this
so i went to my friend nick's house the
other day and i've been buddies with him
for a while
and he's got this website called
museumhack.com he recently sold the
business
but this is just another example of one
of these tour things that we've been
discussing
so he i don't even know if he knows a
lot about art
i don't know what his background is
actually but he likes
he just enjoys museums and so he built
this business that was making two
million a year in sales
and you would pay him or eventually he
would train people in a variety of
cities
and you would pay fifty to a hundred
dollars i forget the plus admission to
the museum and
in new york the museum's free and he
would give you a custom tour of a museum
and explain you explain to you the the
background behind the different
paintings and different pieces of art
but you would do it in a fun way so if
you go
if you google museum hack the meta
description is museum hack
[__] awesome museum tours so it was
like clearly like this like young hip
you know whatever thing and companies
would pay money to send their employees
there
and they do it in six cities i think so
they have people in la san francisco new
york and then a few other cities
and it was a 2 million a year business
and this is all that he did
and it was very successful it was a lot
of work to set up but it kind of ran
itself after a while
and pretty simple and straightforward
and pretty amazing it's called museum
hack that's the business that's cool
i like that one um you had two stories
is that the one is that both or is that
one
that was both okay that's both can i do
one more idea
we want to try to slip it in all right
so this is related to
related to manhood as a service more
like back to the roots which i think
kind of like what you were talking about
was like
i'm gonna buy a farm i'm gonna like own
the farm and i'm gonna like offer tours
of the farm and let people come like
farm with me
uh or a ranch or something like that
right anytime i rent the chicken i'm
looking at the site now rent the chicken
is what i want to talk about so
what i saw this little thing that showed
that that's talked about how
the chicken rental business has been
booming during the pandemic
okay what is this people are renting
chickens like pet it's like a pet in a
box so chicken
kind of owners breeders i don't know who
real farm people basically
are taking chickens and basically saying
hey sam
who uh you know lives in austin and you
know has his house
do you want a chicken coop in your
backyard here's what you get
hey there's two chickens back there cool
you kind of got a little pet
i i'll bring the coop i bring the feed i
bring the instructions i i kind of boot
you up i
let you know how it works they're gonna
lay like six eggs uh you know a a a day
or whatever like you're gonna get fresh
eggs that are awesome from your own coop
and you got this pet uh like you get to
talk to them and pet them and
like i know for example my daughter is
like 18 months old
like kids love animals and so i want to
get her like some kind of animal soon
that's like
like because we have cows that come in
our backyard or like back to our fence
and it's like her favorite thing in the
whole world just like cows couch and she
says like
you know khao si mu kelsey moo like
means like i want to go see the cows
they go moo and so i take her to the
fence and she sees them and she's like
wants to touch them and it's like
her favorite thing our friend ramon had
a little chicken coop in his backyard he
had three of them
three chickens back there and his son
like liked it and they used to go out
there and you know feed the chickens and
get eggs from them and so this is
booming so they're all like sold out so
all the
chicken rental companies can't get a
chicken right now
they're all like totally booked the
demand during the during the pandemic
like tripled
i think it's still small numbers because
they were like oh yeah demand triple
last year we did 70
70 we had 70 chickens to rent and now we
have like 200 chickens to rent so it's
like
that's still not that many coops that
you're renting out pretty amazing
but i'll call this my this is my new
segment called
blue collar side hustle i may never do
this segment again but at least for this
no we're going to do that that's a good
one blue collar
blue collar side hustle this is a way to
make a few thousand dollars episode this
whole episode is blue collar side
hustles i think actually cool so so
we talk about side hustles where it's
like oh make a newsletter build an
audience
build a job board build a website that
does this do drop shipping blah blah no
no
blue collar side hustles things you
could just do with your bare hands
make money with your bare hands so
here's how it works whatever city you're
in
there's probably demand for these
chicken rentals where you are too if all
these other ones are sold out
uh there's probably demand in those
cities and in nashville and in florida
and in la and in everywhere so rent some
coops basically go get some chickens
and start renting them out to people who
want to
be connected with nature have a little
pet in their backyard that's low
maintenance and get some fresh eggs
so i think this is a great idea as a
simple way that you could be making i
don't know what it is
you know five to ten grand a month of
side hustle income
through your blue collar side hustle
dude and this website rent the chicken
they also have a thing
called buy the eggs or something like
that and
you can find out where the so rent the
chicken yeah they put you a thing near
you and then they have a thing where you
can find out where the nearest one is
and you can buy the fresh eggs from your
which is cool right so you can go farm
to table but you're just in the city and
you're just getting it from somebody who
lives
two miles away they also do this with
schools which i think is again smart
because kids love this schools and
offices
hey are you a school in office great we
can do a six-week program where you get
chickens for six weeks you guys get to
name them take care of them
pet them blah blah take you know kids
are gonna have fun
and then we move on which back when i
was in school we had the same we had
like a
class pet for like you know everybody
got to take them home for two weeks or
something like that
um you know so we had that you have like
a beekeeper thing or like you're a
beekeeper you have bees
bees and honey maybe bees and honey is
like another little
genre besides chickens but i think
anything where it's a simple low
maintenance pet
that is unorthodox and ideally provides
a little bit of food you can eat so
eggs honey something like that i i think
that that is a really
cool fun thing to do again dude your
growth
you were working on growth i said i got
to find something good and
then i just closed my eyes and started
typing buttons and this came to me
this is uh very cool so if
rent the chicken is not okay so it's
here's the price for houston houston's
near san francisco they deliver to you
for free it's only 285
for a five-week rental february to
october they deliver and set it up for
free
you get seven eggs that are gonna uh be
hatched
you get a box i think you get one
chicken
this is so interesting 60 bucks a week
right
60 bucks a week to have you know a
ticket or two in your backyard making
eggs
oh rented chicken rent the chicken is
cool i'm into rent the chicken
i went to um a party the other day and
it was they had a
backyard petting zoo and like a petting
zoo delivery service
kids party at an adult's party it was an
adult's party and they had
it was basically all the backyard no it
just means they they have chickens
they have a guinea pig and i think
that's oh and rabbits
and uh that's what this reminds me of uh
rent the chicken backyard petting zoos
i'm into all this [__] man i like all
this stuff this is
this is a good one i actually think this
is something i might sign up for but
they're not in austin
um my but my friend who had a chicken
he said the eggs looked different but
they didn't taste different
but i would feel a lot better eating
backyard eggs than store eggs
for sure um can i then let me switch
gears real quick
how do you stay focused because when i'm
doing this
so i'm like i'm all in on podcasts right
now like that's all i think about that's
all i'm
it's almost it's almost all i work i
work on i have
200 unread texts i've got hundreds of
voicemails
i get phone calls from like salespeople
selling me crap my email is ruined
twitter sucks my slack is constantly
beeping
it is so hard to get the zone in focus
how do you do it
um well i would say this
i am not a details person
in general so i would say one of the
ways to stay focused
or one of the ways to get [__] done i'll
instead of saying stay focused i get
[__] done
is to correctly identify like you said
the 80 20
of any project so for you you were like
for the podcast okay what do i
ultimately need to do i need to get
people to smash the subscribe button so
how do i get more people to hit
subscribe today
right so you you focused on the thing
that matters
and you threw away the rest and then you
like did the what's the one step i can
take today
to like get that to happen more and then
tomorrow i'll come up with another one
and
the next day i'll come up with another
one so that's you didn't say it in so
many words but that's how i
operate i identify what is the thing
that if i just did this one thing it's
going to get me 80 percent of the return
or the reward or the impact and then i
try to just set out okay today i gotta
get this one outcome done
and that one outcome might have like
five tasks five like subtasks underneath
but i'm like okay if i can correctly
identify the high impact thing
and then secondly if i can just narrow
it down
you know make it a memorable like i
don't do a to-do list
it's one thing that i can remember in my
head all day that this is the one
outcome i gotta get done
i'll find a way to get it done it won't
leave my brain i don't let my brain get
cluttered by all the ten other things
and this bothers the hell out of my wife
or like right now my mom's staying with
us right she's helping out with the baby
and she's like oh you got to get your
car insurance thing done oh and hey did
you know
your trash thing we should upgrade the
thing so you get the bigger bins because
your bins are overflowing
and like all these people texted you
because it was your birthday on sunday
did you reply to any of them like no i
i didn't do any of those things i don't
plan to do any of those things
none of those things are in line with my
chief aim right now so like i'm gonna
like focus on that and it doesn't matter
what the chief aim is right like
we just had this baby my chief aim was
like i'm gonna be
so helpful with this baby because like i
can see my wife this is like
she's gonna drown otherwise this is too
hard to have two kids under 18 months
old
i need to be like mr mr helpful and so i
like went all in on mr hopeful
but if it's a project like let's say
growing the podcast that's what i would
do
identify the 80 the thing that will give
me 80 of the impact
make it every day just choose one high
impact thing to do like it might be
get booked on other people's podcasts
other big podcasts i know that's going
to drive
attention cool i'll only do that thing i
won't do anything else
so what you're describing uh i actually
wrote about this i have this article
called i'll do it later
why you shouldn't worry about
procrastinating and it was written in
2015 so i wrote those six years ago
and basically and i stole a lot of ideas
from other people so i won't take i
don't want to act like i invented this
but
there's basically three types of
procrastination there's the first type
which is you do nothing
and that type is easy a lot of people
suffer from that and that's what you
want to avoid you don't want to do
number one the second one is doing
something less important than what you
should be doing
a lot of people do that too and that's
basically when you
uh you know you have to do this uh
school homework
but you play video games instead right
no no it's like you clean your room
it's like you you do some false
productive thing when you didn't need to
do that you should have been studying
for the test tomorrow
yeah it's called bit it's busy work and
it's meaningless and that's actually the
worst type of procrastination because
you actually think you're doing
something productive in reality you're
not
um and that's really dangerous but the
third type of procrastination i think we
should all embrace and it's actually the
good type of procrastination
so it is when you when you do something
that's more important than the stuff you
should be doing
and that's actually what you just
described so getting your car insurance
is actually important
but what's more important let's say this
relates to business it's just making a
ton of money
to the point where that car insurance
kind of like is it's you understand that
it's less important
and the best example of this is like the
brilliant scientist who accidentally
wears two left shoes or
who forgets to shower or who doesn't
take their trash out is taking your
trash out important
it's important but it's far less
important than creating the theory of
relativity you know what i mean
and so actually biology said something
about this the other day because we said
what's your day like and he goes
i um you know he's like we said kind of
like dude you're thinking about all
these topics like
the future of x and the you know the the
future of y
and the past of z these are heavy like
these are meaty topics to think about
like how do you do that every day
and he was like actually that's not so
hard for me that feels like play like i
enjoy doing that
what's hard for me is remembering that i
have a you know i have a call i got to
be on in 10 minutes
and like stopping what i'm doing getting
there on time and remembering to go do
that thing is like because i get
completely engrossed in what i'm doing
and that becomes easy but what becomes
hard is like normal life
and i was like yeah you're you are the
absent-minded scientist
who's got like his desk is like you know
totally messy it's like to someone else
it looks like chaos
but you know that you're piecing these
things together and you don't care about
organizing your desk right now it's just
not what's important to you
and the thing is is that logically we
all know that the third type of
procrastination is good and you should
actually embrace it but the world
basically tries to beat that out of you
and they try to totally hate you in this
corner
and make you vanilla and they say but
sean you have to do your insurance
or you have to text these people back
and the answer is often
or it should be like but why actually
it's far more important if i do x y and
z
and i have found this extreme question
but helpful question
to ask yourself is uh will the tasks
that i'm working on right now
be mentioned or be part of me being
mentioned in my obituary
and if it's not then you're
procrastinating don't don't
don't don't do that work on the thing
that will be mentioned on your obituary
or has a chance of
uh yeah like i actually got into
argument with my wife yesterday about
this because we have some bill
that's like we have like a 700 late fee
on it and she was like oh my god we're
so wasteful like
why didn't you just pay this bill i told
you about it i put it on your desk
and i was like uh and i was like yes you
did put it on my desk but i was so
knee-deep in learning about defy the
last three days and hey guess what like
we've made
you know sixty eight thousand dollars in
three days on in this defy trade that i
was making
and um like that's cash in the bank now
like could we not worry about the 700
thing and so for me it's so black and
white but she comes from a totally
different value set
which is like it feels worse to her
to take something that was avoidable um
that you could have just taken care of
that would signify adulthood
uh that you're on top of your bills and
um and for me it's the exact
opposite my values are you know focus on
the things that matter
and like let other [__] fall on the
ground and like that stuff is on the
ground for a reason i just hop skip and
jump around it
um and so we are so different and we
constantly get into these arguments
and i feel like financially i'm on the
right side of history
but um you know in the house i'm
definitely losing rounds every time we
do these battles
so if your wife is listening to this and
she does by the
my wife does which is weird um but if
show her this episode
and to anyone else out there who like
fits in this like scientist type of
forgetful scientist thing where they
forget
birthdays or they do this and they do
this but they're really actually focused
on like
some interesting thing that will
actually change their life or others
lives
let it slip let it slide do not give in
to this
societal pressure of like having to
focus on these unimportant things
because you should instead be focused on
things that actually matter your health
whatever you're working on in your
family everything else is pretty much
[__]
yes so can i get one can i give my last
last piece on this but i know we're
going to move on in a second but i have
i have
two minutes on this which is i made a
choice a long time ago all right the way
i realized how this works
is there are people who are pre there's
unproductive people they're just lazy
they don't get [__] done okay you don't
want to be one of them
then in the productive class there's two
types of people there's efficient
productive
and there's effective productive i'm
effective productive you're effective
productive
there's a lot of people who we work with
in fact we have to hire people that are
efficient productive
what they do is they get a high number
of tasks done
and done well but they don't necessarily
correctly identify
the one or two tasks that are going to
have disproportionate rewards
and they don't go overboard on those
tasks so if you look at us well that's
what we're going to do
whether it's project selection or even
within a project we will find the one or
two things that will
drive the most returns we will go give
that 120 180 percent
and then we will do zero percent on the
other things whereas another person
might say and and by the way that might
all happen in a two-hour burst
of work in the day or a four-hour late
night binge
uh and the other hours of the day were
completely you know we were
scatterbrained we were doing other [__]
and it didn't matter
there's other people who say i'm gonna
work from nine to five i'm gonna make
every hour count
i'm gonna get a whole bunch of things
done i feel good because i plowed
through my to-do list i was so efficient
i used every
hour properly and i got a large number
of tasks done
um and i you know i tied up all these
loose ends that's efficient productive
so
decide which one you're going to be both
have pros and cons i think for a ceo
entrepreneurial type effective
productive is better um or at least
i've seen that's a more common path to
success i should say so that's one
the second thing is just like you said
that there's procrastination
um i you you left the cody sanchez
podcast last time but at the end we
talked about this where she she was
talking about finding mentors
and i stole this novel quote which is so
true
when people think they need a mentor to
go do their project or to like start
their startup they're looking for a
mentor first
it's just an advanced form of
procrastination um
you will find mentors along the way
you'll find people who are super helpful
who have experience they'll guide
they'll open doors they'll guide you
but uh that is not what's stopping you
from making progress right now
and if you are looking for mentors
before you do the thing
uh you are procrastinating you're just
doing it in a way that other people
can't point and laugh at because you're
not just eating cheetos and watching tv
as your form of procrastination and the
final point
the final point is there is a class of
things
and right now for example i i do this
list i i've done i've
put this in my frameworks pdf that if
you if you go sign up for my my
newsletter on seanpuri.com this is the
first thing i send you is my
frameworks pdf i have this like iron
cross or it's called an eisenhower
matrix it's basically like a
a two crossed lines and the up and down
line is basically
impact so low impact to high impact and
the left to right
is urgent and non-urgent and so on a
given day you want to do the things that
are urgent and high impact
but what it but so that's obvious but
then what do you do next and once you do
those two things what do you do next
do you go to the bucket that is urgent
but low impact or high impact non-urgent
and what most people do 90 95 people
including myself on many days
is we'll do the urgent low-impact thing
we'll pay that bill
we'll call that person back we will um
you know whatever it is
uh type those loose ends because they're
due today or they're due yesterday
but there's a whole other batch of
things that are important and non-urgent
they just sit there like ticking time
bombs
and the great quote around this is that
you know what's important
but non-urgent um becomes urgent very
quickly and what ends up
you know it becomes urgent when it's too
late uh so like
for me right now this is setting up my
tax strategy my overarching tax strategy
how do i manage
do i need an estate do i need to trust
how am i going to do all this
i don't know about that [__] it kind of
makes my mind bend a little bit
it's easier for me to just avoid that
because there's no like there's no
specific day where i have to get that
set up but every day that i don't i'm
not doing something that's a you know
high impact or a very
large large impact thing and so think
about the
things you do on this axis and then try
not to just
avoid those things that are non-urgent
and high impact because
that's actually where a lot of value
gets driven i uh i'm doing all that [__]
now i can't stand it so
i agree i think we had a good little
rant on procrastination on
uh productivity okay great good episode
that's it that's a wrap abray you give
us the grade people hated when we put
the grade up front i got like five
messages being like i prefer it
uh i prefer at the end all right that's
good
all right everyone i asked you to either
leave a review or subscribe
and send me proof and hundreds maybe
even north of a thousand people did i'm
not gonna read all your names right now
but i'm gonna get to everyone eventually
but i'm gonna give a few shout out or i
wanna give a shout out to a handful of
people
that did it so uh here's everyone who
subscribed and sent a screenshot if you
wanna get a shout out you could do the
same
my email is mfm at thehustle.co so it's
my first million mfm
sorry at the hustle.co subscribe
to the podcast and send me a screenshot
and i'm going to read your name
so give a shout out to sam dickey to
alex khanna
to apostolos oh this guy
i think he's a greek guy apostolos d
delandis
adam guskey ryan bennett zach rosen
rob barowski alex rodolfi
briarin sanders sanders
will sweat rob phillips richie
dawes and then here's a bunch of people
on twitter who hollered at me with um
with um a review and a proof of
subscription so
paul halsapp jimmy montrief
warren smp cameron walker
willie soxy saxey
mooney millions
ms mclean ellie lager oh my gosh i'm
really sorry guys i just for some reason
i have an issue
where i i struggle to pronounce certain
stuff uh
danny dolly k3 goodman
louis shulman dave m smith
cheese three solar wolf
faff coffee wade w wireless
landon h7
uh and that's that's it for right now
i'm gonna get to the rest um next week
but we'll see if if this is even good
and people like this
but go ahead and subscribe to the
podcast send me proof that you've
subscribed via a screenshot send it to
mfm at thehustle.com and i'll try to
read your name
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back